what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i'm going to be reacting to rumors
featuring little dirk
before i start
do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell if you've watched
two or more of my videos and you have
not subscribed i mean you have beef
beef okay
all right let's watch
them [ __ ] get on y'all ash i'll play
with me like ain't worth trying to
[Music]
sorry i'm eating pizza bread
he's saying
all you guys
think you're cool but you're gossiping
about me i don't appreciate that
guys if you have a conflict with someone
say it to their face do it
say my name first he a junkie he ain't
shot his gun yeah he blamed perks shot a
video and
okay
so he's sam i'm a cool guy because i've
shot in a video
and i've shot at people now i don't
really think shooting at someone makes
you cool
it makes you uncool on my eyes but
i guess nowadays
this is what the women want the shooter
okay
what you know about popping out and
trying to hit they face first they like
smirk your ass be trippin better put
your case first choking who i hurt the
woman's [ __ ] better play slow
[ __ ]
so
he's saying he heard stuff through the
grapevine sorry i gotta pause this a lot
because i'm trying not to get
copyrighted this time
also i don't understand why why do you
have cash just holding it out you're
like asking to get robbed
do none of you worry i worry when i i
hold like my camera in public
it's like 500 bucks you guys are
thousands of dollars just in public oh
no oh no no no
so you catch i want the one i paid for
we on this ass here in the air you see
how long they stay for ain't no hotel
room we pop outside the height with
dracos
what's a draco
also
they got a lot of friends always
are they just like dancing in the
parking lot we used to do that in high
school sometimes he'll catch they get
off any saying the police chase those
trolling ass we shot your homie we know
he can take those if i say your name
don't post it i'll be on all kind of
[ __ ] ain't got time to watch your page
to see of [ __ ] that a [ __ ]
wait what did he say i don't got time to
watch your what let me go back [ __ ]
ain't got time to watch your page to see
of [ __ ] data [ __ ]
i still can't hear it ain't got time to
watch your page to see
your page
to see if
died
that's not nice no they're not nice
[ __ ] [ __ ] i know [ __ ] set you up
literally [ __ ] down in here in this
industry ain't what it seems that [ __ ]
be counterfeit okay i found out that if
a girl sets you up it basically means
she's like
come on
let's hang out
and he's like okay i think he's gonna
get like to hook up with her
no
she uh
she she's really the other guy comes in
and then like kills you or beats you up
i guess ain't no lagging she say i'm a
[ __ ] from the trenches with an accent
why you asking me who shot your homie
while you acting you got my numb you
pull [ __ ] on
so
he's saying
you are lucky i don't do things for
instagram
i do i live my life on my terms not for
the world for me and you guys are lucky
you guys are cowards that's what he's
saying like
i'm the cool one
i'm the one who's not afraid but you
guys you're afraid
i never drunk it cooler what is a cooler
what is it aidan ack
let me know in the comments i do not
know what that is
he jumped in the streets he's a hooper
so he's taking shots like um
in basketball i'm a basketball player
took a shower
my retirement he gonna kill you for that
catch him in the morning wake him up
he took it to trial i tried to tell him
it was stupid that gave him so
i
really like his rap right there
that was fun that was a fun one
he was losing watch the [ __ ] you say the
face be listening to the music and they
gonna take your leaves and build the
case and try to use it d.a drop my
murder didn't have evidence to prove it
i think my house is honey about who the
ghost of pool okay so he's saying be
careful talking on the phone because the
feds might be listening but sarah why
why are the feds listening
look i've lived i'm 25 i've lived a lot
of life
the feds have never listened to my phone
calls
i don't think
no no they wouldn't i
haven't done anything
why on earth are the feds listening to
you
that chain has to be heavy that just is
impractical
like why on earth would you want to
carry that heavy chain you ever think
about what that does chiropractically
like that's gotta be harsh on your neck
nobody thinks about these things
he ain't killed nobody but keep rapping
about the shooting still ain't got
revenge but keep making no excuses oh so
he's saying he hasn't killed anybody but
you're rapping that like you have so you
sir are acting like you're hard but
you're not
and you just keep on making excuses do
it do it i dare you
cause then
oh my gosh he wouldn't he had his rubies
so like his chains maybe or like jewelry
and he wouldn't give up his jewelry so
he got buried oh my gosh one
there's nothing that is important enough
to like die over i do not
i have some nice jewelry
not really i have like one nice ring and
it's not cool enough to be honest
that i would die for it like how how
expensive are these
chains like over a thousand
then i believe
wrestling
okay i don't care this is a bop though
i'm shimmying
so he's about to cougar i had to stop it
because again copyright but he's saying
basically an old lady
that's hot
he took a shower so he he's he's
bragging a little bit he's letting you
know he gets the he gets the females
bringing my retirement he gonna kill you
for that moodle catch him in the morning
wake him up that boy a rooster cheering
production
okay
um i enjoyed this song i'm very sorry i
had to stop it so much today it's not
it's not what i want to do
but i'm really tired of being broke and
these always get copyright struck so i
could never do them anymore
so
i would give that a four out of five to
be honest i really enjoyed that song the
themes i didn't like so much um
you know i'm gonna give it a three out
of five just because
i i'm just not a fan of like the themes
but i really like the beat like i was
you know shimmy and you know what i mean
but yeah
out of five three
yeah cause he was talking about like
killing people that's not nice but guys
if you've watched two or more of these
subscribe to the channel poor footwork
don't forget to
subscribe leave a comment and i'll talk
to you guys next time